I dropped out of college to do this and
it was one of the best decisions of my
life because it combines technology and
dogs two of my passions college did not
hit those buttons Phil Kimmi co-founder
and director of software development
Rover comm Rover is the best place to go
find a dog sitter or dog walker that's a
perfect match for your needs whatever
your needs might be so you can find
somebody usually it's a neighbor
somebody who will treat your dog just
like you would so you can go on vacation
and come back and not have any stress
about leaving your dog with this person
so you'll get photo updates while you're
out of town and your dog will have a
great time
often just staying with a family or or a
person just like you we started in 2011
at a startup weekend which was a event
where somebody pitches an idea and then
the team forms organically around it so
my co-founder Greg got Aspen had a bad
experience with his dog Ruby when he
probably about 10 years ago where he
left her to kennel and she came back
with kennel cough and was stressed out
and had just really an awful time and at
the time we also saw that Airbnb was
becoming really big so he actually
initially said Airbnb for dogs so I was
back home for the summer from my
undergraduate degree and had kind of
intentionally been seeking out something
to do for the summer so I joined the
team and little does I know that I would
still be doing it six years in some
months later
when we first were starting this I don't
know that we knew how big the
opportunity was but it turns out that a
52% of US households with income greater
than $100,000 have dogs and that's you
know it's statistic and it's there's a
large number large percentage in all
other demographic groups as well so the
opportunity here is actually massive and
if you look at existing commercial
solutions it tends to be around it's
around a six billion dollar a year
business and if you look at our
customers they actually mostly didn't
previously use those commercial
solutions so instead they went to their
friends or family and you know kind of
used their favors instead of their
dollars to find a sitter so we wanted to
get in the middle of that transaction
and help people find some they're
satisfied with who's actually there and
wants to be doing it instead of feeling
like you're leaning on your friends to
do it instead
[Music]